what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by today today we
have a very interesting topic to discuss
Marvel Studios lately really before
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 had been
getting a lot of flack recently phase
four started off strong with one
division Loki and the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier plus not to mention Xiang
Chi and other strong Marvel movies but
since then many fans have been stating
that the quality of Marvel Studios has
gone down since the launch of phase 4
and Disney plus now what's interesting
about this is that Marvel in a way has
sort of acknowledged this in recent
events that have taken place Bob Iger
the CEO of Disney who got brought back
into Disney after he retired to
essentially fix some things that were
going on as stated publicly that they
are going to focus on producing less
content but start to worry about
producing better quality content and
Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studio said the same thing and it looks
like we might have found what the
problem was with Marvel Studios also
lucasfilm apparently as well as some
writers who used to write and work with
Marvel Studios and lucasfilm have come
out and spoken up about what exactly
they went through and what exactly the
recent process has been and this was
done in kind of an exposed piece by
Maureen Ryan from Vanity Fair her Expos
titled burn it down and this gives us a
little bit of a look behind the curtain
of Marvel Studios hearing from her
sources which are as I mentioned some
veteran writers who have met and taken
meetings with Marvel Studios and thanks
to what some of these writers have told
us we have learned what is or what was
kind of happening at Marvel Studios that
may have caused that lack of quality and
cohesiveness with Marvel Studios movies
and shows now this video isn't an
exposed video we're not trying to expose
Marvel Studios for anything bad we are
simply going to talk about the process
that happens in The Writer's room and
how it's actually getting better in
Marvel Studios and Disney are taking
steps to actually improve the quality of
content that they put out and really
just kind of lift the MCU in general to
a better quality and go ahead and let us
know right now what you thought about
phase five in the comments down below
did you love it did you hate it were you
in the middle what are your thoughts
also phase five as well we have Ant-Man
on the wasp quantumania and Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 3. so like I mentioned
this piece goes into the writer's room
over at Marvel Studios particularly
talking about the Disney Plus shows and
keep in mind this was kind of a new
process for Marvel Studios Disney plus
gave them the opportunity but also the
pressure of producing shows for the MCU
now so they had to get a writing team
together and it had to operate kind of
in a different way because they were
used to writing movies and not TV shows
and So what had happened according to
multiple TV veterans and sources of
marine Ryan's they had said that there
was a big lack of autonomy with Marvel
Studios meaning that the writers didn't
actually have the full writing control
over the project that they were working
on and they stated that many times the
actual show Runner or show Runners for
the show were instead labeled as the
head writer of the show and then Marvel
Studios Executives were listed as
executive producers this isn't really
anything bad but according to a TV
veteran who is referred to as Steve not
putting the actual real name of the
writer out there according to Steve
Marvel executives are often in the
writer's room and according to another
Rider that goes by the name of Emma
again not the real name but they're
trying to remain anonymous according to
Emma lucasfilm is pretty much the same
way and this is kind of where the
problem starts writers who are in charge
of writing the actual show aren't really
in charge it seems like these Executives
from Disney and Marvel were in the room
to basically make sure that the story
goes a particular direction one of these
insiders stated that they do have
writing teams that are helmed by a head
writer but they are still ultimately
overseen by a Marvel executive almost
all the time and according to this Expos
it's states that some of the people that
are put in charge ultimately lack
experience and due to the sheer volume
of Marvel Studios Disney plus projects
that they were releasing they state that
there's just too much to juggle and not
enough time to learn for these
Executives and I would also Imagine for
the writers as well if they are being
told that they do need to fit a certain
story within kind of another story to
make it connect and here's where it
actually gets pretty interesting because
it doesn't sound like it's Kevin feige
sitting there in the rooms because some
insiders say that it wasn't always like
this and Kevin feige was actually the
one before who would essentially go
around and make everything kind of
better they state that Kevin feige used
to go around and be the problem solver
on the movies and that is specifically
talking about movies they go on to say
that now there is simply too much
happening with Marvel Studios everywhere
for Kevin feige to do that which is why
everything is wildly uneven as they put
it and this no doubt is due to the pure
vol volume of Disney plus projects that
Marvel Studios is being put out and at
the end of this they basically stated
that and I quote here the head writers
are not running any show they have no
real power so what is seemingly
Happening Here is they have Marvel
Executives that aren't exactly the most
experienced people in the world in the
writer's room sometimes going against
what the writers are actually creating
or maybe having them do something that
wasn't really intended to be in the
story but the real question is has this
changed has it been fixed over at Marvel
Studios and the answer is seemingly yes
or it is at least in the process of
being fixed and it all comes back down
to Kevin feige and Bob Iger stating that
they are indeed going to kind of slow
down producing these Disney Plus shows
and no doubt this is one of the reasons
that they are reducing the content
output for Disney plus they need better
quality control they need better
cohesiveness between them and the
writing teams Kevin feige couldn't run
around and put out all the fires before
and keep the peace but if they cut back
a little bit on the Disney Plus shows he
certainly can do that that and having
Bob Iger on board with producing less
content and not kind of pressuring
Marvel Studios to actually keep pumping
out these Disney Plus shows to make more
money and get more subscribers is really
nice and as part of what is going to
actually help and fix this problem and
we gotta give Marvel Studios a little
bit of slack here because this was brand
new for them they only did movies up to
phase four when phase four came it was
an entire new boat it was completely new
and they had to do something they've
never done before before Kevin feige was
able to let the writing team write a
film and him come in every now and then
and include his opinion on it or say hey
something needs to go a specific way how
can we make that happen but it seems
like with the Disney Plus shows since
there were so many happening at one time
so many going in development at once he
had to assign other people to do that
and of course nobody is going to have
the knowledge and the passion and the
dedication that Kevin feige has
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is a
pretty good example Kevin feige
basically let James Gunn one right he
sat there sometimes and had his opinions
with James Gunn like he told James Gunn
you don't want to be known for the first
guy to drop an F-bomb in a Marvel movie
do you in which James Gunn said no yeah
I absolutely do and Kevin feige let him
do it so Kevin feige was there he was
helping oversee the script writing and
the story but ultimately let the writing
happen because he trusted James Gunn now
with the Disney Plus shows a lot of new
writers are brought in and if Kevin
feige isn't really meeting face to face
with them one-on-one too often then it
might be kind of hard to sync up Visions
or how the story is supposed to play out
in the MCU how they Envision it and what
Kevin feige wants included in it but now
it seems like it's going to get a lot
better secret invasion is supposed to be
a very great show and everything else
that we have coming up is supposed to be
really good as well since Marvel Studios
is going to cut back a little bit on
producing those Disney Plus shows or
spreading them further out which Kevin
feige said they're gonna do both produce
less but also spread them out a little
bit more this gives him personally a lot
more time to go and sit down down with
each writing team and kind of sync up
and talk about the overall vision and
quality of what is supposed to happen
this should make Marvel Studios Disney
plus projects a lot better so if you
haven't been too happy with them this
should be giving you hope and if you
have been enjoying them this is just
even more exciting because they're gonna
get even better and I just want to add
if you love the current Disney Plus
shows that have been produced and put
out their support that is super awesome
don't let anybody else's opinion change
that but overall great news for Marvel
Studios their process looks to be
getting a lot better and hopefully we're
about to get some pretty killer Disney
Plus shows and of course movies as well
sdcc is coming up in about a month
hopefully we get some pretty cool
reveals in the meantime let us know what
you think about this video in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video And subscribe and leave a
comment because that enters you in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 and
Xbox series X so Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well don't forget
to follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and you can check out our patreon
account our website and our Discord
server we'll link those down below as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof